for the past four days GameSpot's next
big game coverage of evolve has shown
you what each hunter class can do to
help take down a towering enemy and
achieve glorious victory today is the
day that the tables turn so you want to
know what it takes to be the monster as
both predator and prey you will hunt and
be hunted using deadly attacks and
evasive tactics to assert your dominance
the Goliath stalks along the ground
leaping to cover distance but you Kraken
you can fly and that can make all the
difference in the world
unlike the puny human hunters who start
with the same arsenal they end with your
beastly abilities actually grow over the
course of the match through the
judicious application of skill points
you get a few to start off with and a
few each time you evolve to be a bigger
badder version of yourself evolution
isn't some kind of long-term crackpot
theory here you merely need to gobble up
some of the local wildlife and find a
safe spot to evolve after a brief stint
as a vulnerable writhing horror pile you
stage up and can gain new powers or
improve the ones you've got how you
develop your skill set has a big impact
on how you approach combat so let's get
acquainted with the Krakens
particularities a good starting point is
vortex a swirling projectile Maelstrom
that deals damage and scatters the
hunters like bowling pins little angry
gun-toting bowling pins a big key to
murdering your pursuers is keeping them
from grouping up on you and a good for
Tech's hit can help you disorient the
team and isolate a hunter for some
one-on-one thrashing it can also kill
the critters living on each map that
you'll need to eat to restore your armor
and build up the fat reserves you'll
need to evolve I mean I assume it's bad
but monster physiology is a bit of a
mystery at this point honestly I think
ignorance is bliss in this case and
before you chide me for my lack of
curiosity let me introduce you to
banshee my
fancy mines are glistening pulsating
orbs excreted by the kraken that hover
on the ground until something comes near
them then homed in on that something
while emitting the screams of a thousand
children do you really want to know
where those come from I didn't think so
these explosive terror balls can help so
chaos among the hunters during combat as
well as provide audio clues about the
hunters position if you drop them behind
you like a breadcrumb trail
alternatively you could just spew the
mines down a random path to create a
little misdirection and rely on the
monsters sniff ability to sense when
your prey is near crouching and doing
the old sniffle snuff is a great way to
set an ambush for the hunters but with
the Krakens ability to fly you're more
likely to be floating like an
antigravity squid demon and stinging
like the thunderstorm
the Krakens to lightning fueled
abilities really help reinforce the
whole Lovecraftian eldritch god thing
you've got going on lightning strike is
slow to charge and hunters can see where
you're aiming it by the crackling
electricity gathering on the ground
cackle menacingly as you watch them try
to flee and then burst out in full
throated villain laughs when it hits and
sends them flying if you're not
relishing the moment you nail those
pesky humans with the most damaging
monster attack in the game you're not
doing it right
playing the monster is all about being
the apex predator about chaining
together all your nasty abilities to
tear that team of four human hunters
apart once you've landed a vortex or a
lightning strike and created some chaos
drop out of the sky and melee the crap
out of a hunter preferably the medic
mixing the team's ability to revive and
heal is a crucial strategic step but if
you're trapped in the mobile arena and
you need to get out target the trapper
instead being on the ground has a way of
drawing hunters close to you which
creates the perfect opportunity for the
Krakens last ability aftershock
after a moment or two of charging every
living thing and that crackling electro
sphere you created will get zapped then
it's time to liftoff help the survivors
with airborne projectile attacks and
wait for your abilities to recharge for
the next strike oh the Kraken rarely
will you taste such sweet salty
satisfaction as when you've
systematically slaughtered a team of
hunters who thought you were the prey as
they pursued you and badgered you they
thought you were scared and when they
domed you in the mobile arena they
thought you were doomed but they had it
wrong see you weren't trapped in there
with them they were trapped in there
with you
you